previously on TV since okay snowball
just calm down okay
you're scaring me this is coming to
Brooklyn and it's got buck teeth and a
Cottontail I could just send holiday
inflatables because seriously how did
that become a thing but it's much easier
to sin the fact that you put Rudolph
right in the middle of your driveway
also you shovel an immaculate path to
the sidewalk but only half of your
driveway
what are you monsters put it in the
stocking summer or I'm joining Facebook
a teenager carrying about Facebook
you're adorable 2013 also Facebook is
this a mirror at the bottom of the
stairs was the goal to both check your
appearance as well as block traffic in
the most dangerous part of your home
okay look I know the show is going for a
quick joke here with his giant Morty
Mellon somehow fitting through that
opening but why does the show go to
great detail with some areas of physics
but approach this one by literally
jamming its head up at ol just hold your
breath until the process is over or your
lungs will collapse and then he doesn't
and yet he's fine hey Dad where's
morning he's busy yeah great joke and
all but even bet she'd be a little
surprised at the naked near-death Bad
Santa whose chest her dad currently has
a giant needle jammed into right
welcome to Anatomy roll commercials the
anatomy park train has only one small
entrance exit for a train with three
cars and what is up with these stairs
with no rails that lead to your certain
doom if you fall I love details like a
part in our dust sign for an amusement
park inside a human body and I'm
certainly laughing but who is this sign
full the park isn't open yet and doesn't
appear to be close to opening so there
are no customers affected by it and if
the park has been open this whole time
we're talking about a logistical
nightmare from the customers getting
shrunk and enlarged at the Smith house
without anyone seeing and figuring out
where the hell homeless Reuben is to
inject them into his body well hi is the
saying not a t-shirt why would this
guard be concerned with anybody who
shows up here not like anyone can
illegally trespass into this homeless
person's body unless Rick specifically
inserts them it's weird that the
security guy here shoots bullets at
diseases instead of like vaccines or
penicillin
can we talk about Jerry's sweater for a
second the colors in the middle section
should be reversed so that the red side
since our green and look like Christmas
trees unless of course these are
intentional green arrows pointing down
to an entirely different type of
Christmas cheer I watch them sometimes
from a chair sometimes from a closet
almost always dressed as Superman cut
Kent nearly all human lungs contain a
strain of these bacteria but the scar
tissue keeps them dormant if the scar
tissue has already been tampered with
then why did the tuberculosis wait until
the germ Oliver said something about it
to attack what is that horrible smell
must be your own breath because your
breathing air from inside your helmet
from the attached air supply
so smell really shouldn't be an issue
keep your eye on any she was written up
several times by her manager at the
churro stand later on Annie will say
actually I studied dr. blooms work so
did she get written up because she was
constantly in dr. blooms lab learning
everything seems like someone who was
allowed to study the work of the main
boss wouldn't be stuck at the churro
stand getting written up for whatever
reason this also seems to indicate that
the park was open but I still haven't
gotten a definitive answer on that good
gonorrhea conscious if we don't why
would you be thinking of a goddamn t-rex
because of the movie Jurassic Park that
you're referencing throughout the
episode like dinosaurs and infectious
diseases are in any way related enough
to confuse the two
if it works will be regular-sized in a
few minutes you mean there's a growth
ray inside Reuben this guy jokes about
Reuben not being in a room with white
carpet or upholstery and good for the
show for thinking of the gnarly
aftermath of such a move but seems like
in a world of impossible science they'd
have found a way to escape without the
grisly measure that's bubonic plague so
a couple questions here first why did
you leave it roaming free in your
backpack pocket if you had this plan to
sell bubonic plague to the highest
bidder wouldn't you have a container to
put it in second why the hell was there
bubonic plague inside Reuben what the
hell
[Music]
I'm sorry does the grandfather really
think that his wife and Jacob are going
to have sex right now on the couch while
his granddaughter and her boyfriend make
out in the same room the aristocrats
also did these closet door flaps open
individually like this or even at all
what you like to ride the bone train why
are you doing this bit we're gonna die
Gordie would be retorting @tv sins
[Music]
because those are clearly bacteriophage
viruses and e-coli is a type of bacteria
and not a virus suck my fat virology
expertise Rick wads would this fuse
continue being lit while in space my
guess is no but I should probably send
myself for even thinking about it when
it comes to an episode about an
amusement park inside of a homeless man
reports from all over the country have
been coming in about what appears to be
a giant naked man over the continental
United States how fast did those reports
come in exactly Rick just kicked him out
of the spaceship and enlarged him like
three seconds ago I'm pretty sure that
dynamite would have exploded before any
news outlets had the chance to make
their detailed naked guy graphic
overlays I guess I'm gonna have to be
that guy and point out that Reuben is
now the size of the entire continental
US so his face should be covering way
more area than a city block agreed but I
have to ask is there even gravity now
that inner space has gone to outer space
what the when the bone train went off
the rails hepatitis-a was looking at it
go past him and crash into this nipple
area even if he jumped to grab the train
how would he have gotten inside and the
time it took for the train to crash
did we have some sort of relationship
with him I think they're just like that
I think they're just good guys gladly
remove the soon wouldn't this life is
rough picture show the golf ball
actually in the rough rather than on the
green where the hole is actually I
studied dr. blooms work IIIi believe I
have the knowledge necessary to create
an entirely new much safer Park Jurassic
world that's it that's the sin that's
Atari 2600 Donkey Kong sounds coming
from these 2013 devices it's time to
upgrade our gadget noises Hollywood
sounds like you got at least two people
in there already are you saying there's
several in my gear get to the digestive
tract he's coughing oh god it looks like
a huge
[Music]
Oh as always a bigger fish